hello y'all good to see y'all look good
well first of all billy congratulations
on your directorial debut what is it
like moving from an on-screen superstar
to director extraordinaire
well thank you for the extraordinary
part um you know
it's been a dream of mine
for
a couple of decades to um
get behind the camera and
be at the helm of telling
um
our own stories
um making sure that
um
the narrative and the archetypes
um that haven't been seen before
are represented
with truth
um and so it's
a gift it's a blessing it's a dream come
true
it's bliss it's all of those things um
and i am just
humbled to be here really truly yes yes
eva and abu bakr did i say that right
yes
nailed it
it worked so hard to work so hard okay
uh billy porter of course is a legend
but what was it like working with him on
this project and what's the most
surprising thing you learned about him
i mean billy's a light every time i have
a sandwich
right now but it's true that's really
the only word i could think of is that
he's a light
um yeah i don't know what would you say
i'm gonna have to think of something
surprising so you can stall i mean i've
been saying the same thing too working
at billy is a dream truly i mean i
learned so much every single day
i learned to trust myself more
i learned to just lean into the joy
and really to just like have fun you
know i think that was the biggest thing
like this was my first movie so i was
super nervous putting way too much
pressure on myself every day
and billy was like girl you better just
breathe you know
so yeah
yes billy why was this the perfect story
to tell for your big debut
well i have to
say and reiterate
that this story found me
um
you know i set out
decades ago
i chose myself
i chose my authenticity at a time
when
it was not popular you know i always say
it's easy to be who you are when who you
are is popular
um you know but i made a decision and a
choice
to build to fill the void yeah you know
the void that i saw in the market
there was no representation
for me or anybody like me
you know and so i set out like i said
decades ago to fill that void
and so this piece
literally dropped out of this guy for me
you know christine vashon dj guggenheim
david hanojosa andrew lauren they had
this script and they had the idea yeah
for me
from seeing my work
and following me in the marketplace they
understood
that i was probably the person to be at
the helm of telling this story and i am
so grateful yeah for that you know
because um
it's everything i've ever wanted to do
and be
oh
it really truly is you know it's
unfortunate that in 2022 we're still
breaking down barriers
but
it's so wonderful to be breaking down
barriers um there's some really
incredible moments you know it being a
teen rom-com
with a black trans girl as the leading
lady and love interest and then on top
of it
having someone abu bakr like for you
having someone land the lead role um
with your background and all the things
that it's not white just say it period
we're hearing white people don't get us
wrong
we love you white people
but there's an egyptian man who's just
as fine as y'all
may be finer than some of us
[Laughter]
and it's time honey it is time
for you guys eva and abu bakr for you
guys you know a film having a film like
this when you were younger
how would it have impacted you to get to
see that sort of representation when you
were young
no like i think when you when you're a
kid you always kind of latch on to some
you know kids like live in a space of
pretend and pretend is stemmed from kind
of what you see outside of yourself
so you know
when you have something that that you
can pretend to be that you see as a kid
it really like you could just stand like
a couple inches taller i think so at the
end of the day i think you know kids
after watching this i hope
will be able to just stand a little
taller more confident and you know more
joyful
yes yeah yeah you know i i mean yeah
like seeing something like this when i
was younger it would have made me feel
so much more seen
it would have made me feel more
understood you know i mean you know we
can just think about the reach that this
film is going to have
there are going to be so many little
trans kids in the smallest of towns
who don't even have the language for who
they are yet who will see this and be
like oh
that's me you know like i
can do this i can be myself and i can be
happy you know i think that's a really
really beautiful thing yeah that's
awesome thank you guys so much for your
time
you